because dire maker was my favorite
zeppelin song you're like that's a poser
zeppelin song yeah and that's another
thing with these bands is like when you
come into them late you don't know the
different albums or eras you just know
the hits and so you don't even know
which songs are like like when i told my
dad my favorite rolling stone song was
wild horses he's like oh you're one of
those guys yeah that's
one of my buddies his his parents like
followed them around on tour for like
two years and they hate wild horses yeah
and it's like their favorite band of all
time and i and i was like it's probably
my favorite and he's like that's
everyone hates that who really likes
them i think because they're hard
hitting bands and people want them to be
like you know just kind of a
like a fist to the audience then those
songs are like really nice they're great
and they become good and what selling
out is a term from like music you know
where you change for like your sound for
this or that
and we've seen bands go through that i
didn't watch zeppelin do i just had
their whole catalog and i was like this
is rad dude and really enjoyed it